they have these amazing cognitive
abilities they're more like feathered
apes
this is betty she's a female raven she's
the biggest of the corvids and corvids
in general are very very intelligent
birds
they can creatively problem solve so
they can put together sort of sequences
of behaviors that they've learned
into a novel way to solve a problem you
can see she'll look at things you'll
[ __ ] ahead you actually see her working
it out what is it can i can i benefit
anything from that the hard part is
trying to stay one step in front of her
[Music]
so there's a classic military
line that says improvise adapt to
overcome and that's a really positive
way of thinking about anything it's
about
trial and error and the resilience to
keep going new caledonian crows create
multi-step tools which are essentially
tools that are
strong and thick at one end and thin and
flexible at the other end
and that means that they are able to put
those tools easily into crevices and
extract food items
albert einstein described compound
interest as the eighth wonder of the
world crows really understand compound
interest so when they save that bit of
food and bury it in the grass they know
that over time maggots will come in and
from the crow's perspective they'll have
even more food it's found its food it
saved its food and now it's buried it in
the ground somewhere where it gets
compound interest on its investment
she's burying food in the summer you've
got flies flies lay eggs maggots hatch
out the eggs when she goes back to the
food not only she's got the the rotten
bit of food she's cashed anyway but
she's got she's doubled it in size by
having all the maggots on it as well
for a long time it was thought that
delayed gratification was something that
was unique to humans and non-human grey
apes and some primates but it has been
found that corvids will delay
gratification so they will deny
themselves an immediate reward in order
to get a reward of a better quality in
the future they form really long-term
relationships and those relationships
are themselves an example of delayed
gratification crows have absolutely
nailed delayed gratification there's a
seminal book called the marshmallow test
by walter mitchell which studies young
children and as they've grown up and
their ability to delay gratification
their ability to look at a marshmallow
and wait and if they wait long enough
they'll get two what that study showed
is that those children were able
later on in life to be better at
managing money better at managing
relationships healthier
more likely to do exercise more likely
to eat well so delayed gratification is
the key to sort of putting off those
short-term gains for long-term benefits
no
no
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video